hey thanks so it's always wonderful to
come back to Berkeley I did my PhD here
and my first theoretical neuroscience
class was taken with Bruno and Fritz so
anyway it's great to come back here see
the amazing new buildings and all the
progress Berkeley is made so yeah I'm
gonna talk about emergent elasticity in
the neural code for space so this is
joint work this is a series of papers
this is a series of papers there's a
series of papers and joint work with
several talented people so Kia
Hardcastle is a graduate student jointly
advised between me and Lisa Jacomo Sam
ocoa is a theorist in my lab and Malcolm
Campbell is an experimentalist and
Lisa's lab and all of this work is a
very close collaboration with Lisa
Giacomo without whom none of this work
would have been possible we're very
lucky to have her at Stanford so what
are the key questions we'd like to
address we'd like to try to understand
how do we know where we are in an
environment and what does it even mean
to know or learn a map of the
environment and in particular how can
known mechanisms of local synaptic
plasticity learn a map of a new
environment over time through
exploration so there's an area in the
brain the medial internal cortex which
has neurons that have very high-level
abstract information about the
environment for example this area has
border cells that fire if and only if
the mouse is at a border this is a heat
map of the firing rate of a single cell
red means high firing blue means low
firing and and these are the positions
that a mouse can explore in a in an open
field and so this is a border cell that
fires if and only if the mouse is at a
border it has speed cells whose firing
rate increases monotonically with speed
it has the famous grid cells that fire
if and only if the mouse's of the
vertices of a hexagonal grid and the M
EC also has head Direction cells that
fire if and only if the the angular
position of the the head of the mouse is
in a certain narrow range but it's
important to realize that these abstract
quantities like speed position and head
direction
are not directly available at the the
sensory periphery of the animal instead
these abstract representations internal
representations space have to be
constructed for much lower level signals
coming safe from the retina which tells
you information about the visual
position of landmarks and also provides
optic flow that can be used in the
computation of velocity these
information this information also has to
be integrated with low level
proprioception that tells you how your
body is moving through space and also
efferent motor commands that your brain
sent in the past to tell your body how
to move so information has to be fused
between these low level signals to
construct these high-level abstract
variables like velocity and position
okay
so we'd like to understand how this
computation arises and we're gonna focus
for most of the talk on the highest
level of a computation which is how you
integrate information about landmarks
and past velocity which you can then
integrate to finally compute position so
any spatial map forming circuit must
obey a fundamental consistency condition
that relates path integration to
landmark based error correction so
imagine for example you're moving in an
environment and you see landmark a okay
so that triggers a pattern of neural
activity pattern a and then you walk
from from landmark a to landmark B so
then path integration of velocity
evolves this neural activity pattern to
a new pattern B prime now let's say that
instead you just directly saw landmark B
and that elicits the neural activity
pattern B self-consistency means that
the that pattern the activity pattern B
must equal the activity pattern B prime
obtained from first seeing landmark a
and then traveling to landmark B so the
question is again how can known
mechanisms of neural dynamics and
synaptic plasticity solve the
self-consistency condition in any that
that's required of any spatial map
forming circuit so here's the outline of
the talk will first show that landmark
correction is indeed something that
occurs we'll provide evidence of the
stability
grid cells does arise due to continuous
correction by encounters with landmarks
okay then we'll develop an analytically
solvable attractor model augmented with
plastic synaptic inputs from landmark
cells that can learn a consistent
environmental map through exploration
well moreover analyze this model
mathematically through model reduction
techniques and show that this model
yields a sort of emergent elasticity
where landmark cell synapses behave like
particles connected by Springs whose
rest length is equal to the physical
length separating the firing fields of
the landmarks so then the system
elastically relaxes to solve the
self-consistency condition that I
mentioned and this model is predictive
it makes experimental predictions that
are testable it shows that grid firing
fields have a subtle history dependence
and their firing patterns it explains
the observation of deformed grid firing
fields and irregular boxes and it
actually suggests new experiments it
suggests the potential for discovering
topological defects in grid fields and
then we'll go further and look at new
new experiments involving virtual
reality that alter the very relationship
between velocity and position to make
path integration and landmarks disagree
and then we probe the response of the
internal representation of space in the
mouse's brain when you create
inconsistent conditions and and probing
the the mouse's internal representations
gives us clues as to how this internal
representation is constructed from
low-level signals and we'll have a model
for that so let's jump in
first first you know so this is an
example grid cell the basic question is
does error accumulate in this grid cell
system and if so how and is it corrected
by landmarks so most often you look at a
grid cell just by constructing a
composite histogram of where the where
the mouse was when the cell fired right
or basically the the occupancy condition
firing rate of the cell okay but we
could look at a finer resolution
analysis where we look at the individual
spikes that occur at every single
position conditioned upon time since the
last border touch so here's an exam
were a mouse left a border and went on a
trajectory right and these are the
individual spikes that occurred at
different times along this trajectory
for each spike we compute the distance
to the nearest grid firing field okay
and we normalize that distance by the
width of that firing fields okay so this
is the normalized spike distance metric
and we compute that distance as a
function of time since the last border
touch okay and what we find is that it's
in a normal room with the usual distil
Q's and so on and so forth so there
could be some error correction due to
distil Q's but but as you'll see there's
a strong dominant effect due to landmark
correction from the borders that's that
can be detected even in the presence of
any further potential correction okay so
here's that for a single trajectory
here's the normalized spike distance as
a function of time and you can see that
it increases almost by a factor of two
so remember one is you know about the
width of one away from the firing field
center within 40 seconds right so this
tells you that potentially these grid
cells rapidly decohere in the absence of
landmark correction within a time scale
of about 40 seconds okay this is the
summary data for all the cells and you
see that it's it kind of grows over time
so basically the stability of this
beautiful grid cell firing pattern is
likely not to arise from highly accurate
path integration of velocity but likely
arises from continuous correction with
landmarks okay in this case the
boundaries for this particular
environment
okay can we characterize the nature of
this error so there's two possibilities
for the growth of this spike distance
metric one is that firing fields are
just becoming more diffuse over time
right or two there might be according to
a tractor based models or a theoretical
models of these grid cells there might
be some coherent drift in a certain
direction for each of these cells now
these cells were individually
recorded we don't have population record
large-scale population recordings so a
question is using individual cell data
can we discriminate between this option
or this option right it turns out you
can if you think about it a little bit
so what you can do is these these two
options make very different predictions
about the where the spikes will occur as
a function of the angle between entry
and exit to the grid field so for
example if you have an individual grid
field and you just mark with a plus one
if the spikes occurred outside the grid
field and with a - with a minus one if
they occurred inside the grid field and
you take the product of these things if
there's an isotropic expansion the
product of the entry and exit spiking
event indicator will be flat it won't
depend on the angle of entry and exit
but if there's a coherent shift then if
the angle is small the product will be
positive but if the angle is large the
product will be negative okay so we can
just plot this product as a function of
angle and average over sells it
interestingly so this is the yeah so I
didn't want to get too much into the
details of this but basically the the
one indicates whether a spike occurred
outside the center of the grid field
upon either entry and exit and a minus
one indicates if no spike occurred just
outside the grid field but without going
into details this particular
experimental signature indicates a
positive to negative transition as a
function of angle between entry to exit
for the coherent drift but a flat
condition for the field expansion and we
find in the experimental data a
significant slope in this thing
indicating that there's a strong
contribution from coherent drift to the
error okay so we can rule out one
possible option another thing also
further evidence that the boundaries are
correcting the error is if you just
think about it if you hit a boundary you
receive positional information let's say
you hit the west boundary or East
boundary you receive positional
information perpendicular
to the boundary but you don't receive
any positional information as to where
you are parallel to the boundary so if
you resolve the error into the parallel
and perpendicular components you should
see preferential correction of errors in
the perpendicular directions of the last
border touch but not necessarily
parallel to the last border touch and
again without going into details this is
what the bar graph tells you that errors
are preferentially corrected
perpendicular to the last border touch
relative to parallel to the last border
touch okay so so now given that there is
indeed strong evidence for landmark
correction in the grid cell code let's
try to model or come up with an
analytically solvable attractor model
for this this phenomenon okay so the
basic idea is we're gonna follow past
work and just assume the existence of a
let's say we're modeling grid cells in
one dimension so we're just going to
assume the existence of an attractor
network where you can imagine the cells
are placed on an abstract ring and
there's local excitation and long-range
inhibition okay the structure of local
excitation long-range inhibition yields
a manifold of 1d stable activity
patterns or attractor States
corresponding to bumps of activity we
can summarize the the state of the
attractor Network the steady states of
the attractor Network by the phase of
the attractor Network which is by
definition the position of the peak of
the bump on this ring so the entire
attractor state can be parameterized by
a single number the phase okay now how
do we get the system to path integrate
we're again going to follow an old idea
set forth by sampson ovitch and
McNaughton and augmented to two
dimensions by barak and feeds which is
basically you have these conjunctive
position and velocity cells whose
efference synapses onto the attractor
network are shifted such that if a cell
who that is selective for eastward
velocity eastward motion of the mouse
has synapses that are shifted clockwise
so that whenever the mouse is moving
east the the shifted synapses will cause
the bump to flow clockwise and
conversely whenever the mouse
is moving west the West conjunctive
velocity selves have synapses shifted
the opposite way so they'll cause the
bump to flow counterclockwise okay so
you can set this up in such a way that
the rate of advance of the attractor
phase is proportional to the velocity of
the mouse and so then what happens is as
the mouse is moving along one direction
the bump moves round and round the
attractor phase so if you're in a rut
lecture physiologist sitting outside and
recording one cell you'll see that cells
firing rate oscillate as a function of
the position of the animal so that's
like a 1d grid cell and other cells will
also be similar 1d grid cells with the
same period but a shifted phase okay so
that's like one module of a grid network
in one dimension yes again these are old
ideas what we're adding so this is the
basic ideas the mouse moves the
attractor phase moves okay now what
we're adding is the influence of
landmarks we assume that a landmark cell
is a sensory driven cell for example a
border cell or more generally any cell
that fires if and only if the mouse is
at the location of a particular landmark
now we assume that this cell has
efferent synapses on to the attractor
Network such that when everything is
learned what they do is they this excess
excitation pins the attractor phase to
the learned pinning phase of this
landmark cell where the pinning phase is
by definition the location of peak
synaptic input from the landmark cell to
the attractor network okay so basically
when this landmark cell is active the
the phase of the attractor Network will
become pinned to the pinning phase of
the landmark cell okay now of course
none of this solves the self-consistency
condition I mentioned yet because what
might happen is the landmark cell likes
to pin the attractor Network at a
certain phase but when the mouse
approaches the firing field of the
landmark cell the attractor phase and
that may not be at the pinning phase of
the landmark cell so this is an
inconsistency condition and so what
we're going to use is where you're going
to use heavy and plasticity of these
landmarks else in APS's in such a way
that one would hope
that if there is this inconsistency
condition then the landmark cell
synapses will learn to shift their
synaptic strength to the location of the
phase where that where the attractor
network is okay and we can do that using
hebbian learning okay so I've been
giving you just pictures to explain
everything intuitively
but don't worry there are equations
underlying all this but also don't worry
even further because I won't show them
again all right yeah yeah so there's an
adjustable parameter which is the
strength of landmark cell input and that
can be adjusted and there's a range over
which it works what's really interesting
is that there should be even higher
order regulation that can adjust that
parameter as the reliability of path
integration and landmarks vary right for
example you can destroy landmarks and
paths initial work in the absence of
landmarks just fine for a certain amount
of time according to our data about 40
seconds right so we do have that
parameter the strength of landmark cell
inputs okay so this is the full this is
the these are the full neural dynamics
equations so this is it's kind of like a
neural field model where s of U is the
firing rate of a cell at position you
and the ring it's just a standard
nonlinear neural network dynamics with
the translation invariant connectivity
that has a local excitation long-range
inhibition and then WI of you is the
synaptic strength from landmark cells to
landmark cell I to an attractor cell at
position U and the neural ring and this
operates on a slower time scale T and
it's basically just heavy and
associative learning with weight decay
okay so this represents a complicated
infinite dimensional dynamics of neurons
and synapses where neurons are evolving
according to their own Niroula dynamics
that are affected by the synaptic
dynamics and the the landmark cell
synapses undergo hebbian dynamics so
we'd like to understand this complex
coupled interplay between neurons and
synapses and you can do this basically
by model reduction okay in a situation
Landmarks l input but there's extra
additional landmarks l input here to
chew the dynamics of the neurons but in
a situation where the landmarks l inputs
are weak enough that they don't change
the shape of the attractor bump but just
cause it to flow you can summarize the
entire neural dident near onal dynamics
again by a single number the attractor
phase of the landmark it evolves due to
path integration but then the pinning
phase of the landmark cell also plays a
role such that whenever the position of
the mouse is within the firing field of
the of the landmark cell then and this
is the parameter Peter that you're
alluding to the strength of landmark
cell inputs but whenever the landmark
cell is firing then there's a pinning
force that pulls the attractor phase to
the pinning phase of the landmark cell
and again because the bump shape isn't
changing hebbian plasticity will learn
to make the efferent synapses on to the
attractor Network some superposition of
bump States that is itself a bump state
and you can summarize the synaptic
strength of an entire landmark cells
synapses using a single number the
pinning phase and so basic model
reduction of these equations yield a set
of finite dimensional equations that we
can intuitively understand so here's a
situation where the landmark phase is
evolving due to path integration and
being pinned by the pinning phases of
the landmark fields but the pinning
phases the landmark fields themselves
are evolving to learn the average
attractor phase that occurs whenever the
landmark cell is firing ok you can you
can add multiple grid skills you yeah
it's easier with grid cells you don't
necessarily need grid cells to do this
that's absolute true you do need some
kind of in this framework at least in a
tree you need them one-dimensional
manifold of stable activity patterns you
will generalize to 2d next yeah yeah
it breaks down if the velocity changes
extremely rapidly so what what happens
is what happens is over the range of
velocities we see that this this model
sort of works but what happens is in
most experiments were the mouse does a
rapid movement it's going from one end
of the border to another one border to
another so then the border would just
correct it right so you'd have to do
sort of controlled experiments where
there are zero landmarks look at
variable ranges of velocities and see if
the grid cell code Chico here is more
rapidly than you'd expect
under faster velocities and slower
velocities and no one's done that
controlled experiment to my knowledge so
where we will talk about a virtual
reality experiment at the end it's not
this exact same experiment but yeah I
mean in ILA's models for example she
also sees that if the velocity is too
fast then you get slippage in the
attractor mechanism
yeah I'll show you yeah I'll show you
they're all coupled that's how we're
gonna get to an elastic system of
landmarks so okay so so look at Ilyas
there's question imagine so how would
the system work just in a simple toy
problem imagine a situation of the mouse
is moving back and forth in a 1d
environment with two landmarks so west
border cell in an east border cells say
so what does the dynamics of learning
look like in the reduced model so so
first of all the mouse starts off with
the West landmark and let's say the
landmark cells are pretty strong so they
pinned the attractor phase to the
pinning phase of the West border cell
right then path integration advances the
landmark sorry the attractor phase okay
until it gets to the east border cell
now this is before learning so there's
nothing guaranteeing that the the final
attractor phase after path integration
equals the pinning phase of the east
border cell okay so then what will
happen is the east border cell will pin
the attractor phase to the pinning phase
of the east border cell but also the
east border cell synapses will be
plastic so the pinning phase will move
slightly closer to the phase of the
attractor Network okay
then again path integration will [ __ ]
the phase back to something else here
but again before learning there's no
guarantee that the pinning phase equals
the attractor phase once the mouse gets
here but pinning will move the attractor
closer to the pinning phase and
plasticity will move the pinning phase
closer to the attractor phase okay and
after several cycles of exploration you
will be at this happy equilibrium where
the phase advance due to path
integration equals exactly the phase
difference between the pinning phase of
the West border and the pinning phase of
the East border okay and vice versa
okay and in this happy situation all of
the phases of the attractor network
assigned to different positions on the
track become independent of which border
cell you came from okay so for example
in the middle you get the same phase
regardless of whether is coming
whether you're coming from the left or
the right okay so that's kind of what
the learning process looks like can we
say something more general and rigorous
about it we can so one way to think
about it is to take the attractor phase
which is fundamentally a circular
variable and unroll it
think about unrolled phase to make it a
linear variable if you do that then you
can think of the landmark cell synapses
or more precisely they're pinning phases
as points sitting in unrolled phase and
you can equate unrolled phase with
physical space right again modular the
grid spacing okay so here are two
landmarks cell synapses they're like
particles sitting in unrolled phase and
before learning you start at the
location the the attractor phase starts
at the location of one of the landmark
cell particles and it advances but it
overshoots the other landmark cell
particle and so then there's a force
that pushes this landmark cell particle
out and vice versa if you start here and
go to here you know according to this
picture you over sorry this picture you
overshot so the let the tractor phase
overshoots so there's a force pushing
this landmark cell out okay until you
reach an equilibrium where again the
distance between the landmark cell cinah
synapses in unrolled phase equals the
phase advance to depart that path
integration or equivalently if you think
about equate unrolled phase with
physical position the landmark cell
particles have a distance equal to the
physical distance between the landmark
cell firing fields outside in the world
okay so you can think of this as two
landmarks all particles connected by a
damped spring right and if the two
landmarks all particles are closer to
each other than the actual physical
distance between their firing fields the
spring is under compression and they'll
expand and move apart on the other hand
if they're further apart the spring is
under tension and they'll come closer
together okay so that's an intuitive
characterization of what was going on in
this learning dynamics but we have a
mathematical proof that this is true for
arbitrary environments in d dimensions
for arbic
three numbers of landmarks will restrict
ourselves to D equals one or two I was a
string theorist at Berkeley so I'm
willing to go up to eleven but recently
I haven't been doing that yeah yeah you
can add noise and that it kind of
averages out over the noise so you can
add noise to it and it slows down the
learning a little bit but but but it's
robust to that because you're always
doing this it's like adding noise to a
spring particle system right there's a
relaxation all dynamics that gets you to
this equilibrium state and if you add
noise you just fluctuate about the fully
understand question we're basically what
we're doing is we're setting up an
attractor Network with external inputs
from path integrated from landmark cells
such at the synapses of the external
inputs from landmark cells learn to pin
the attractor network at exactly the
phase the attractor Network gonna arrive
at if path integration took it there
that's all we're doing okay we can
generalize everything to two dimensions
so now the neural ring becomes a neural
sheets or a torus again this idea has
been used in previous work on grid cells
where basically you have local
excitation and long-range inhibition and
in this situation
Turing pattern formation takes over and
the stable states of the system are
these hexagonal firing patterns on on
this neural sheet okay so the set of all
possible stable states are parameterised
for example by this you know unit cell
which is a twisted torus and the set of
stable points are stable activity
patterns of parameters by points on the
on the twisted torus
so then as the animal moves around the
the grid on the neural ring will move
around and if your neurophysiologist
listening to one neuron it will it will
give you a grid like firing field so so
the so this so again these are the
states of the of the 2d attractor
Network as the animal moves from one end
of the environment to another the grid
firing pattern translates and so this is
the set of attractor States that you see
and then if you have a border cell
that's Co active with the grid network
as the animal is moving from point A to
point B the border cell will connect to
all the grid cells that were active
during this motion which is this pattern
and then in the twisted torus what that
does is it sets up a 2d attraction
mechanism such that the attractor state
whenever that border cell fires will be
attracted down in this way but doesn't
feel in that force along the other
direction so every everything
generalized the 2ds in ways that you'd
sort of intuitively expect but now you
have to think about Corrections in
multiple dimensions ok ok so now that
we've generalized A to D we can make
further connections to experiments the
first one is the following is an
interesting prediction actually so we
analyze a situation where you have a 1d
environment with two borders and easie
west-east
asari west border in East border and
then we found sort of path independence
of the internal resistive space but
imagine for example that you also have a
South border so ok so then according to
the equivalent particle spring picture
you have the West border cell synapses
east border cell synapses and South
border cell synapses there are three
particles they're connected by Springs
whose rest length is equal to the
physical separation between each of the
borders because because there are
pathways that go from the oh by the way
one thing I didn't mention what is the
spring constant of the springs in this
equivalent system it's related to the
frequency with which the mouse goes from
from point A to point B or landmark a to
landmark be so so this picture takes
into account not only the geometry of
space
but the statistics with which space is
explored as you'd expect because
plasticity picks up on statistics in
general okay so now again when you have
the South border cell what happens is
the South border cell is also connected
to the east and west border cell through
Springs so what happens is this extra
interaction from the South border cell
doesn't allow this equilibrium
separation of these particles to be
equal to the rest length of the spring
what happens is the equilibrium
configuration actually leads to some
compression than spring which means that
the phase advance due to path
integration actually overshoots the
phase difference between the pinning
phases of the landmarks so now you
should get some history dependence in
the grid cell firing field and if you
work it all out what it predicts is the
following if you compute grid cell
firing fields but conditioned upon the
last border touch you should see that
the the grid cells are shifted towards
the direction of the last border touch
okay there's a few steps of logic that
lead to that prediction but that's the
prediction and furthermore if you
condition on trajectories in which the
mouse leaves the West border it'll be
[ __ ] the grid cell firing fields be
shifted a bit a little bit west relative
to the other option of conditioning on
the East border okay these shifts are
pretty small according to their model
that their order of magnitude one to two
centimeters so it can be a little
difficult to find these small shifts
especially when grid cells are noisy so
we looked for these shifts in a very
large dataset collected from Lisa
Giacomo's lab yeah in a fully learned
environment the shift will be present
yeah so that's that's true everything is
consistent if there's only two border
cells but when there's a third border
cell I mean everything's consistent
threeway but not pairwise right like
think about it this way right if this
spring will not be able to settle into
its rest length because there's extra
tension contributed from these two
Springs okay the equilibrium separate
the equilibrium length of the spring is
not the same as it would be if you erase
this this interaction that's all I'm
saying
in any case hopefully you understand the
the experimental prediction which is
very simple just a slight shift of the
grid cell firing fields even in a fully
learned environment with no deformations
towards the direction of the last border
touch so again it's a small shift so we
looked at a large data set of about 800
cells from Lisa Giacomo's lab and the
way you can detect such a shift is to
cross correlate that say the West
conditioned border touches the firing
fields condition on West border touches
against the firing fields conditioned on
east border touches up to some spatial
lag and compute how much you have to
shift the West conditioned firing fields
say East to match the east conditioned
firing fields and what we find though so
this is the cross correlation between
West and East conditioned firing fields
according to the spatial lag with which
you shift the West conditioned firing
fields as a function of space and you
find that you have to shift them east to
achieve maximal correlation and not
really north or south okay similarly we
can ask how much do we have to shift the
South conditioned firing fields to make
them maximally match the north
conditioned firing fields and we find
that we have to shift the South
conditioned firing fields north in order
to get a maximal match and the shift is
about two centimeters as predicted ok
there's some related work by Vijay
Balasubramanyam and colleagues who also
modeled attractor networks and found a
similar shift in deformed environments
ok so there's another famous result that
these grid cells deform if you put them
into an irregular
right and there's actually believe it or
not phenomenological models where these
individual grid cells are grid self
firing fields are like particles with
inter atomic potentials with repulsion
and attraction and it turns out they
predict the data but there's no
mechanistic basis for thinking about
individual grid cell firing particles as
atoms that repulse and attract each
other but it turns out in this alternate
emergent elasticity framework where the
landmark cell synapses are pulling and
tugging on the grid cell attractor phase
you actually get this in this
mechanistic framework you actually get
these bends so this is experimental data
and this is simulated data from our
model and it's very easy to understand
intuitively why these bends are coming a
border cell that fires along this border
will tend to pin the attractor phase and
the two-dimensional twisted torus along
a certain manifold of phases right and
then the position at which the mouse
next mouse's grid cell next fires
depends on moving a certain distance
away from the border and that distance
will evolve to you know depending on
where you are on the border so basically
you get these grid cell firing these
bending patterns here you can also
visualize the bending by looking at the
phase assigned by the attractor Network
as a function of physical position all
right so here's a you know part of
theoretical neuroscience is not only to
explain old experiments but maybe to
suggest new experiments right so here's
an interesting experiment it turns out
that both of these grid cell patterns
are stable okay this firing pattern has
three grid cell firing fields on top and
three on the bottom but this only has
two on the top and four on the bottom
right so there's a topological defect
here why is it why is it stable so it
boils down again to winding number
remember the consistency condition is
let's say that you have border cells
here and here the phase advance due to
path integration better equal the phase
difference between the the pinning
phases right so you could achieve this
consistent condition with a winding
number of one here or a winding number
of two here
right both of them are equally
consistent and it turns out they're both
stable under the equations but how do
you create the topological defects okay
well you can create it through a
sequence of deformations and I'll go
through this quickly basically you start
off with an environment where there is
no topological defect you you kill off a
chunk and there these landmark these
rich landmarks that continuously pin the
attractor
so you chop off one corner and then you
stretch it out right the attractor face
will be dragged with the pinning faces
the landmarks and then you close it back
so this border cell has a chance to also
exert a pinning phase here and it turns
out this will be perfectly stable right
so this is an experimental protocol for
introducing topological defects in grid
cells which is a completely new class of
experiments that I've never seen before
and I hope somebody will do it Lisa and
I have other things we're working on so
we're not gonna do it actually so that I
hope that entices other people to do it
okay so okay so now let's go further and
and actually try to probe how these
internal represents are constructed even
further and a great way to do that is to
just alter the laws of physics right
we'd like to alter the laws of physics
and then see how the neural
representations respond to these altered
laws of physics and the way we're going
to do that the way this was done in
Lisa's lab is through these virtual
reality experiments where you alter the
very relation between distance moved as
measured by velocity and the degree of
advance of the world as measured by
vision okay and we can model this and we
find that our model yields a dynamical
phase transition in which grid cells can
break free of landmarks and remap okay
so again we're probing this final
correction stage between how landmarks
and velocity signals are fused to
construct an internal neural
representation of position okay so
here's the bit hopefully the so here's
the basic idea here's the mouse it's
it's going to be walking on a ball this
is this is an experimental setup
developed in david tanks lab and as it
walks along the ball
the world will move forward according to
how fast the mouse is moving in the ball
so hopefully this works okay there you
go so the mouse is moving fast the wall
the world is moving fast mouse stops the
world stops moving and so on so this is
a baseline condition where the mouse
gets experience with this virtual
reality environment so what what a
Malcolm and Lisa slab did was he
measured grid cells and border cells
both in a 2d environment to identify
that they really were a bonafide a grid
cells and border cells and speed cells
and then he looked at those same exact
cells in the virtual reality environment
in the same recording session and he
found that grid cells in the real world
behave like grid cells and virtual
reality border cells in the real world
behave like border cells in the VR in
the sense that they were their firing
rate was tied to landmarks and speed
cells also behaved like speed cells so
that's great the mouse kind of thinks
the virtual world is a real world right
or at least the mouse's mean you're a
natural ronald cortex things done I
don't know what the mouse is thinking I
wish we knew that would solve a lot of
problems in your science okay now we can
control the system so we can change the
rate of advance of the of the visual
scene in response to how much the mouse
moves so for example so this is like a
baseline condition with the mouse's
moving at some velocity and this is the
rate of advance of the world okay so we
could consider a gain increase where
this for the same number of steps of the
mouse the world moves much faster
or we could this is sorry gain decrease
the world moves slower so you can see
for the same velocity of the mouse the
world is moving slower or we could do a
gain increase where for the same
velocity of the mouse that the world
moves faster okay so now the question is
how does medial at Toronto cortex
respond to these changes now whenever we
do a gain increase or a game decrease we
do this in blocks of
just five trials right interspersed with
long periods of the baseline condition
so we do not allow the neural
representation to learn we probe the
response of the neural representation in
response to a sudden perturbation and
then put it and then take it away okay
so as usual with all of these things the
data came first and the model came and
the data didn't make sense we had to
come up with a model to understand the
data the model made predictions and so
on which we helped us to reanalyze the
data but I'm a theorist so I'm gonna
present the model first so how would we
model this thing again we're gonna look
at the same attractor Network whose
phase advance is due to path integration
presumably driven by both optic flow
signals and by locomotion of the legs of
the mouse okay but at the same time it's
a cue rich environment there so there's
a continuous sequence of landmark cells
that are active in sequence so initially
when the mouse approaches one landmark
that will have one pinning phase and
then as a mouse moves forward it
approach another landmark it will have
another pinning phase and so on so
there's a sequence of pinning phases
marching forward in time as the mouse
moves and also the attractor phases Matt
is going forward in time partially
driven by path integration of velocity
but also driven by the pinning phases so
you can model this couple dynamics
between path integration landmarks
literally as a system of coupled
oscillators okay so basically the face
of the path integral a path of the
attractor Network again advances to do
path integration the landmarks advance
again due to the velocity of the mouse
or internal a sum of the velocities
mouth Mouse at some rates okay but
that's just the advance of landmarks of
visual landmarks and then the landmark
pinning will drag the attractor phase so
this is literally a Kermode oscillator
model okay and we know a lot about
coupled oscillators so when the whole
system is settled and learned what will
happen is in the baseline condition the
phase advance of the path integrator the
red arrows will always equal the pinning
phase of the attractor network and
everything will be fine
sensory cues and
and velocity cues are all in register
and everything's fine we model the gain
increase or gain decrease by a change in
in one of these constants in ka for
example what that does is it changes the
frequency of one of the oscillators and
we know a lot about coupled oscillators
with different frequencies right if the
frequency difference isn't too large
then what will happen is you'll be in a
subcritical situation where let's say
the so this is baseline where we're
landmarks and path integration agree in
a subcritical gain change or a small
gain change what will happen is there'll
be a slight mismatch in frequencies so
the attractor will say lag the landmarks
but they'll move in register with each
other there'll be a constant phase lag
what that leads to is if you plot grid
cells that as a function of position on
the visual track there'll be a phase lag
between the gain change condition and
the baseline condition okay and that can
be detected by a shift in the cross
correlation between firing patterns
before and after the game change however
if the frequency difference is too large
that the coupled oscillators cannot
entrain each other and essentially what
happens is let the attractor phase can
break free of the landmark pinning
phases and go in a complicated dynamics
so essentially when visual cues and
proprioceptive cues mismatch they're so
when they mismatch to a great extent the
path integrator just breaks free and
then what will happen is the grid cells
will remap okay and so there'll be a
drop in the cross correlation between
baseline and gain change okay so just to
show this so this is a situation where
everything matches this is a situation
where say for example in a gain increase
this is a weak mismatch and you get a
phase shift in the attractor Network
this is a strong mismatch and you get a
decoupling between the attractor and the
landmarks and so you get remapping in
the grid cell network okay and we did a
Lisa and Malcolm did a weak gain
increased computation I'm kind of
running out of time so I'll make a
strong
a long story short under a week gain
increase we did indeed see a phase
difference between the baseline and gain
change condition and this is the cross
correlation there's a peak at a certain
phase lag and we can make all of this
quantitative in a strong game decrease
condition we saw a destruction in the
cross correlation and we saw remapping
when you saw a strong gain change
intriguingly board of cells were
unaffected indicating that boarder cells
are primarily driven by visual inputs
and they ignore provides option and
there's there's some interesting effects
of landmark friction that we can talk
about and so here's the basic idea there
are these two regimes predicted by
theory under a weak gain change under a
weak gain change you should get a phase
shift in the neural representation under
a strong gain change you should get a
remapping and we see both of them and
now it can end so again this is a
sequence of work some pablor some under
review and again I did love to thank
extremely talented collaborators a kir
Hardcastle Sam OCO Malcolm and again
this is a very close collaboration
between my lab and Lisa's lab and as I
mentioned none of this work would have
been possible but without Lisa and we're
super happy to have her at Stanford all
right thanks
[Applause]
the walls were not as close so I would
imagine that the landmarks are going to
be things like trees or rocks yeah yeah
exactly yes that comes through the
visual system or any other system that
can detect fixed objects right so you
know an Toronto cortex got strong inputs
from all sensory areas so if there's any
stable sensory pattern that that can be
elicited by sensory system and that
stable neural activity pattern has
connections onto the attractor system
and there's heavy and learning then the
whole story goes through right like any
reliable relationship between attractor
phase in the sensory cell will be
reinforced in the synapses from the
sensory cell to the attractor Network so
then when that sensor cell is the next
fire they'll pin it back to the phase
that was there when it first encountered
in the landmark there's interesting
experiments on that lesions of this area
can affect learning learning an
environment but sometimes they don't
affect the ability to navigate a well
learned environment so not bumping into
walls is a low bar for navigation yeah
it's it's it's a it's an interesting
question like no one has done the killer
experiment to show that these brain ears
are obligatory related to navigation in
a well learned environment that's
difficult to show because there could be
multiple brain regions involved
HM could wander around the world I don't
know if he could learn his way around a
new environment he'd never seen before I
mean he couldn't remember a conversation
five minutes later right so it'd be
unlikely that he can navigate or learn
to navigate a new environment he could
navigate his childhood home like
childhood areas like really well which
indicates that as we know there's
transfer of information from the
capillaries to cortical areas so the so
which brain regions contribute to
navigation is a very complicated story
yeah so the people have done lots of
experiments completely in the dark and
play cells and grid cells persist for
some amount of time people quibble about
those experiments because there could be
olfactory cues and other things that are
not destroyed and and so on and so forth
but the consensus in the field is that
you don't necessarily need sensory
inputs for the stability of these place
cells and grid cells for short periods
of time presumably if the landmarks are
driven by visual inputs and you get rid
of visual inputs you you you no longer
have active landmark zones oh you know
one thing I didn't tell you is is that
in this work in the virtual reality work
we also looked at how is velocity
constructed right because in this
virtual reality environment you have two
sources of information about velocity
one is optic flow like just forget
landmarks how fast or how large is the
optic flow and two how fast are your
feet moving and it turns out we can
dissect the differential contribution of
these two signals to the speed tuning
both at a behavioral level in a
physiological level and we found that as
the mouse is moving fast it pays more
attention to optic flow both in
physiology and behavior and what's
moving slower it pays more attention to
proprioceptive both at the level of
physiology and behaviors so it's the
brain I think uses every signal
available to it to construct an internal
representation and when the reliability
of different signals vary it ignores on
reliable ones and pays more attention to
reliable ones Eric
yeah yeah definitely so there are
several effects that might be explained
through chain well changes in the gain
of the velocity cells right so yeah
that's a possibility we didn't need it
to explain the effects that we looked at
but of course it's a possibility in more
general scenarios all kinds of local
dynamic no difficulties like neurons
having different firing rates you have
shorter plasticity of synapses and
probably some history dependence so keV
understand that a beautiful Theory can
sum up norburg for such as crappy
implementation I'm not sure what the
question is because some ways how this
organization principles can override
this local diversity yeah so so we we
kind of modeled an idealized system that
was and that idealized model was enough
to make experimentally testable
predictions which were then verifiable
we're of course not addressing issues
about the robustness of this model to
various perturbation so there must be
some mechanisms for ensuring this
robustness in the face of intrinsic
variability in the level of synapses and
and an interesting side ability of cells
and so on and so forth presumably I mean
there's many many cells that are that
are involved right it's actually one
thing we did look at was pairwise
correlations between grits
and border cells and they were weak
which suggests that a grid cell is
presumably integrating from many many
many speed cells which means if there's
fluctuations in the strength of synapses
from speed cells to grid cells those
fluctuations must be being averaged out
right so you could have a lot of
heterogeneity to single cell level but
if the system is fundamentally operating
in a distributed way that's an easy
mechanism for attaining robustness
whether that is the mechanism or not I
don't know but we didn't need to model
any of that to get interesting
predictions okay sorry